okay another Detroit artist I gotta ask
if they're on your radar
Insane Clown Posse who do you know about
the Insane Clown Posse maybe making that
name up bro you don't know about ICP you
serious
wow Insane Clown Posse hey yo throw me
the remote no no I'm gonna put it on
[__] YouTube
where's the remote so you know
bye something I gotta show you some
jabby walking type [__] Jabberwockies
yes they're like one of the most
they're one of the most successful
Independent Artists ever they like rock
star type [__] no they do they do really
shitty rap music
are they popular they had people ICP bro
they were popping in the 90s they were
like people with the other dudes you
were talking about they were popping
with uh they were beefing with Eminem
man what the [__] they were clown
chasing bro nah they were they were
doing their thing bruh I mean they're
beautiful
wait so you've never seen uh a hatchet
man tattoo on a white trash
hey throw this [__] real bro they have a
Gathering of the Juggalos they have like
a festival in the middle of the
[Music]
oh Millions
terrible hold on let me let me let's do
it real quick and I see Miracles every
day
okay [__] this this is terrible let's
look at it
what you got to do though is they have
this thing called the uh they have this
thing called the Gathering of the
Juggalos there's a drug oh wait this is
actually this is ICP when they were
popping this is from the
as hell
this [__] is terrible right
do you want to know what's crazy about
ICP though check this out they were
designated their fan base is called
Juggalos
and so their fan base was designated uh
official gang by the FBI so their fan
base is considered a gang
what hold on say that again so they have
like their fan base they call themselves
Juggalos yeah
and the FBI designated them an actual
gang
so they're fans but like and obviously
they're not a gang but like it was kind
of an unfair thing
but dude you these Juggalo [__]
there God no God no
so they have like this Festival every
year called the Gathering of the
Juggalos
and it's just like white trash they hang
out
they don't they don't shower much they
do meth
OD
I got on the [__] long ass tee
now that's Detroit where I trash I was
talking about right there so that's what
I saw at that Tech Nine concert be
honest
[Music]
they're from Detroit
these [__] guys wow I don't think
nobody in Detroit none of these [__] I
ain't gonna lie no I'm telling you some
people know them
they're I mean dude they're big bro
they got m's on [__]
they're they're big I mean they're and
the thing is is they're not big in the
YouTube area they're big like in the 90s
and [__]
but like it's pretty it's pretty it's
pretty crazy you know what I think we
need to try to get you booked at the
Gathering of the Juggalos
with them [__] bro I guarantee you you
get a bag over there
it's so [__] crazy bro I'm jugged
them drunk ass [__]
bro the crazy thing is it's like big
Detroit artists have done the Gathering
of the Juggalos
so they have a drug Bridge there
so there's like a drug bridge where and
there's a [__] Hut where [__] just
getting trains around man it's crazy
see look at me educating you on Detroit
Hip Hop man appreciate it man by the way
history you do not need to go back and
listen to any of their music because it
is atrocious you need to dislike them
[__] right now no no they're cool
guys I'm sure like you know I respect I
respect their independent hustle they're
not bad dudes I'm just not a fan of
their music now
J dilla we gotta put you on yeah I need
I need to get hit man ASAP and we got to
get you booked at the Gathering of the
Juggalos you know what they would do so
I never knew
that Insane Clown Posse okay so Faygo
right so I go to Detroit you guys got a
million flavors of Faygo yeah so I
didn't know up until recently that Faygo
wasn't ICP soda I always thought they
owned it because they was like they
talked about it so much or they uh and
at their concerts they'll take like 102
leaders and they have this like Faygo
gun and they shoot the two leaders into
the [__] crowd so it's a bunch of
sticky Faygo drenched white kids who
don't shower
it's interesting yeah you know we should
go to ICP concert together man I think
you already went I've been to one I
actually was late
yeah it was ICP Tech Nine and uh Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony I was in high school
oh man it was like 5 000 people so they
was really like like that dude it's
crazy yeah anyway man well listen I
appreciate you pulling up I already know
you definitely uh got the new one's
album coming out in April right the
album is coming out March 31st oh end of
end of March yes sir March 31st tons of
features Drake goes on there baby face
Ray got a couple people yeah got a coat
yeah oh yeah yeah
and yeah yes sir appreciate you pulling
up bro hey by the way for having me you
had a crazy freestyle go watch that on
YouTube I gotta go see I don't even
remember it that's good